learning happens inside our brain when
new information connects with existing
memory when we are excited or
enthusiastic our brain happens to do
that much better in a famous experiment
American psychologist hands brighter put
cocaine addicts into an MRI The effect
of the drug excited the addict and the
researchers saw a lot of activity in
what's called the nucleus accumbens
German scientists did the same
experiment with young men and pitches of
Porsche cars which cost the same area to
light up when they did it with pictures
of a Daihatsu it didn't what's going on
here as soon as we expect something nice
to happen the brain releases its
happiness chemicals dopamine and
endorphins as well as other
neurotransmitters while dopamine and
endorphins delight us the other
neurotransmitters send information from
A to B this connects new information
from outside the brain with stored
memories inside and that's learning
unfortunately this doesn't mean that
everything fun helps us to learn
shopping for example makes us happy but
as German neuroscientist Manfred Spitzer
measured it only lasts 12 seconds then
the dopamine level drops and we have to
shop more to bring it back up this
happens because the brain releases
neurotransmitters in anticipation of
something nice but once we get it the
dopamine rush ends and the information
exchange slows accumulating new things
therefore doesn't make us happy nor does
it help us to learn being excited about
something for a longer time or being
surprised does for example when we are
excited to plan a trip with our friends
or when we have an unexpected and
inspiring conversation with a stranger
our brain releases neurotransmitters and
abundance and we start recording with
all our senses in high-definition the
synapse is at existing footage from the
long term memory to make it a creative
and memorable experience it's like we
turn on a learn turbo
neuroscientist professor dr. hooter even
argues that young children can learn
multiple languages and so many other
things mainly because of their ability
to be excited and most are excited about
everything until they get held back to
follow their interest by the
expectations of their parents or schools
when learning a new language in a boring
class at age 35 however we have little
left to be excited about and hence we
learn next to nothing professor hooter
believes any 75 year old Chinese man who
falls in love with a young 65 year old
British lady will speak English very
fast if you are able to constantly learn
new things in an exciting way the
chemicals released in your brain are
likely to outlive the pleasures of drugs
or shopping it seems as if happiness and
learning not only come from the same
region in our brain but they also
promote one another what is your
experience is learning a side product of
enthusiasm or can we learn without
passion or interest share your thoughts
in the comments below
you